as we await details of public services
to honor the late senator harry reid
friends and family are remembering
reed's 82 years of life and how he
impacted them one of those people is
former governor and senator richard
bryan as our own david charn shows us
the pair were friends from the nevada
legislature all the way up to the halls
of congress senator reid senator max
blockers from montana a photo of harry
reid and richard bryan is one of the
first things you see when you walk into
the 84 year old's home we would meet
virtually every week or two for lunch
the former governor and senator serving
with reed in carson city and washington
together they were known as the gold
dust twins both of us were obviously
ambitious
uh both of us were very much focused and
uh
i think there was a sense that you know
we may we may go someplace and you did
well we we
surprised astounded many but yeah we did
they did harry and i became very close
and
we introduced more bills than any
two legislators probably in the history
of the nevada legislature from the
nevada legislature to the capitol bryan
becoming governor in the 80s read a u.s
senator he has a very dry wit and i must
say i miss that then together again reid
two years younger the senior senator in
the duo there was an objective a project
something that he wanted to accomplish
he was focused on that and every bit of
energy was applied to that a laser-like
determination leading him to become one
of the most powerful men among many
ultimately the spot that he had as the
majority leader of the united states
senate could not be a more powerful
position in the congress the united
states
brian says he last talked to reed a few
weeks ago we were talking about our
experiences today and reminiscing and
i wish there could have been more times
for us to do that because that was
thoroughly enjoyable two old friends
remembering the life they shared i'm
david charns live local now
again funeral arrangements have yet to
be announced but because reed has so
many former staffers and work with so
many people it is expected of course to
be quite a large event we'll let you
know when we know more